hablamos de salud en directo américa ya
está conmigo en el estudio más romeros a
la mar ayer me regañaron porque yo le
dije que por favor me trajera una buena
noticia pero logré mi objetivo porque
hoy comenzamos con una buena noticia un
estudio que muestra que la vacuna contra
el virus del papiloma humano reduce el
cáncer de cuello uterino de manera muy
significativa no eres el único que hace
caso a los regaños porque te prometo que
todas las noticias de hoy son buena muy
bien algo nunca visto efectivamente es
un estudio publicado en la revista the
lancet que se basa en reino unido- y es
el primer estudio que miro los estudios
los efectos a largo plazo de esta de
esta vacuna contra el virus del papiloma
humano que es no es un estudio clínico
sino que es sobre la población general
las conclusiones son históricas y es que
efectivamente es la confirmación de que
esta vacuna salva vidas repasemos los
datos que dan en the lancet
básicamente lo que vemos es que a medida
que esta vacuna se aplica en edades más
tempranas se reducen más los cánceres de
cuello uterino con el tiempo y la
reducción más significativa es cuando la
vacuna se aplica entre los 12 y los 13
años que es del 87 por ciento una cifra
realmente para celebrar por qué pasa
esto porque este virus se transmite por
contacto sexual es un virus que
recordemos que está en el origen del 99%
de los casos de cáncer de cuello uterino
y entonces lo que es ideal es aplicarlo
antes de que una persona sea sexualmente
activa para dar una última nota de
contexto el cáncer cervical es el cuarto
cáncer más diagnosticado en el mundo en
las mujeres y causa raúl nada más y nada
menos que 311 mil muertes cada año así
que es una buena manera de prevenir este
tipo de defunciones y de mamar y
confiará más en las vacunas hablando de
vacuna nuevamente se aprobó la nueva
vacuna contra el coi 19 el fármaco kovác
sin que que sabemos más de esta vacuna
pues principalmente es una vacuna
desarrollada integralmente en india por
los laboratorios baratos bayón tec y en
los expertos de la organización mundial
de la salud nos hablaron de los datos
del estudio clínico que soportan y que
apoyan esta decisión escuchemos lo
tiene una eficacia estimada de 78%
cursantes
de agua
hubo pocos casos de enfermedad severa
así que es difícil estimar su eficacia
contra casos severos de bilis es
modificado pero es razonable asumir que
es una eficacia todavía más alta
es higher
esta vacuna recordemos que ya es
ampliamente usada en india y que es una
vacuna que usa la traer la técnica del
virus inactivado la que introduce un
virus de cobit que no te contagia pero
te hace desarrollar el sistema inmune es
la misma técnica que es si novak con
algunas diferencias pero la misma
filosofía principales ventajas de esta
decisión es sobre todo que la vacuna a
kovak singh pueda incluirse en el
mecanismo de distribución equitativo de
vacunas kóvacs de la organización
mundial de la salud que haya acceso a
una vacuna más barata y que sobre todo
este fármaco es mucho más fácil también
de almacenar de transportar con lo que
es una muy buena noticia para los países
con unas infraestructuras sanitarias más
débiles entre los cuales podemos contar
por ejemplo américa latina así es mari
debe estar muy orgullosa de esta nueva
noticia que vamos a presentar porque una
española lo hizo un nuevo estudio habla
de las causas del parkinson le pregunto
entonces marc por qué son tan
importantes estos hallazgos la principal
clave de esto es que estos hallazgos
podrían ser lo que abre nuevas puertas a
otros tratamientos contra el parkinson
que recordemos que es una enfermedad
neurodegenerativa crónica desde el
sistema nervioso el estudio se publicó
en la revista nation y es el desarrollo
en la universidad como decías por una
investigadora española la universidad
northwestern de chicago se sabía ya no
esto no es nuevo que la relación que hay
una relación entre la falta de dopamina
y el parkinson la dopamina es un
neurotransmisor
que lo que hace bueno lo conocemos por
ser el transmisor del placer y del
bienestar pero que cumple muchas otras
funciones y cuando no se producen las
cantidades adecuadas se hay problemas en
las funciones motoras en el movimiento
que son los síntomas que conocemos todos
del parkinson pero que ahora se sabe es
ese paso a paso es ese mecanismo y se ha
descubierto que la muerte de las
neuronas que producen esta dopamina
empieza en las mitocondrias son el
equivalente como a los centros de
energía de una célula ahí es donde está
el origen - uno de los orígenes del
parkinson y saber esto tener detallado
ese mecanismo tener detallada esa
información definitivamente abre la
puerta a nuevos tratamientos contra esta
enfermedad que recordemos raúl afecta a
unas 7 millones de personas en todo el
mundo mari terminamos con más avances
científicos esta vez contra el dengue
que horribles enfermedad me medio y casi
me han muriendo pues entonces te
alegrarás de escuchar esto como te
prometí puras buenas noticias hoy este
es un estudio de indonesia que se ha
venido desarrollando en los últimos
meses y lo que hacen es crear unos
mosquitos que podríamos llamar mosquitos
buenos los infectan con una bacteria
llamada bacteria wolbachia y lo que hace
es que en estos mosquitos infectados con
la bacteria se impida la reproducción de
virus como el del dengue o también el de
la fiebre amarilla cuando estos
mosquitos buenos se reproducen con
mosquitos malos que si pueden transmitir
esta enfermedad su descendencia es
incapaz de infectar a las personas con
el dengue escuchemos los datos tan
prometedores que daba la directora de
este programa
es fantástico diría que los resultados
son fantásticos porque pudimos reducir
en un 77% los casos de dengue en las
áreas intervenidas con wolbachia
wolbachia entre versión compact y lo que
es todavía más interesante es que las
hospitalizaciones también bajaron en un
86% de schengen shows o te creés 26 por
cient es un avance increíblemente
significativo porque hay una vacuna
contra el dengue pero que no se puede
dar a la población en general entonces
pues la posibilidad de reducir en estas
cifras tan elevadas la transmisión del
dengue es una muy buena noticia también
de nuevo en américa latina donde
recordemos hay varios países que la
tienen como una enfermedad endémica así
que veremos que ojalá se pueda traer
aquí a la región por un mundo libre de
dengue mar muchísimas gracias por estas
buenas noticias de salud